好 今天來講一個停歷的細節
如果沒有注意到這個細節的話
長期而言你會損失非常多的獲利
那這故事是這樣
就是前幾天有一個學生他說
他在停歷的時候滑架了四點
覺得非常的衰
但是那一單是固定點數外停歷
所以是不會滑架的
就是例如說15209的多單
然後在50點外停歷
所以是掛委託單在15259的地方
然後被吃過去之後你就會成功的停歷50點
但是那個學生他是掛在15259的促架停歷
所以他在停歷的時候就滑架了
所以我今天要來講的比較就是
如果你是在固定點數外停歷的話
你應該用NIT來停歷
還是應該用委託單就是限價委託來停歷
那我直接講答案就是
要用限價委託來停歷
絕對不要用
出價單來停歷
那但是停損的話一定要用出價單來停損
好我就直接講結論
要用出價單停損
但是要用限價委託來停歷
那如果兩邊都是掛出價單的話
你會損失長期而言非常非常多的獲利
那這個原因是這樣的
就是這個市場的基本交易規則是
買進跟賣出的價格會是不一樣的
那例如說在這邊
這個是一個舉例啊
例如說現在這是盤中
雖然現在不是盤中
如果盤中是這邊買進209賣出214
那就是如果你是要去吃對手單的話
你就必須要讓對方一些tick
通常是一個tick
那這個原因是因為
就是你去吃對手單的那個人
是比較急著成交的那個人
就是所以你願意讓對方一點點的價格
也要趕緊成交
那所以什麼時候我們會需要比較急呢
例如說進場的時候
進場的時候都是範圍市價
或者就是市價進場
那停損的時候呢
你也是那個比較急的人
所以你要出價
就是出價試價出場
就是market if touch
就是碰到的時候試價這樣
那你在停利的時候
你是非常不急的那個人嘛
因為停損很急的原因是因為
有可能就是行情就直接往反方向
快速的跳動一個20點30點以上
那如果你沒有馬上
在打到停損點的瞬間即時停損的話
你有可能就會多損5點10點以上
所以停損是很急的
你要馬上停損
但是停利的話
如果直接噴過去
那也沒關係嘛對不對
那所以就是停利的話是掛現價
然後停損的話是掛出價
那有一個非常重要的
這個要講的是
就是有一些券商他的二則一單是兩邊都是出價
那如果是例如說15209的多單
然後你要在5點之外停損
10點之外停利好了
那如果你是掛二則一單的話
可能就是204出價停損
然後219出價停利
那這樣的話
如果二則一的停利那一邊也是出價的話
那你就不要用這個二則一
如果你是固定點數
而不是特殊條件的話
那你就應該要掛的是
這個204這邊停損
然後219這邊掛現價委託停利
然後如果打到其中一邊的話
你再去手動取消另外一邊
欸記得要取消另外一邊喔
因為你把其中一邊出掉之後
另一邊你其實就已經沒有想要空219了
所以就是打到其中一邊
你都要去把另外一邊手動取消掉
那這個是
這個如果你的券商是兩邊
二則一都是出價的話
你應該不要用那個功能
那這個比較的原因是這樣
就是你掛219出價
唯一會損失價值的時候
就是在那個價位是最高點
然後出價但沒有成交嘛
就是209走到219之後
219就是當天的最高點
然後就往下走了
也不一定要當天最高點
就是在打到204之前
就回檔了
那這樣的話就
就會變成一個沒有獲利的蛋嘛
那但是因為台子騎他的委託是
分散在很細的很多tick
你看這邊
每一個掛都是掛個位數嘛
那其實多的時候也大概就是幾十而已
就是委託都是非常非常少的
所以出價未成的情況是非常少的
這真的非常非常的罕見
然後
就是
而且你在進場的時候
你就馬上掛了這個限價委託單了
那所以跟那個AI浮動在那邊掛委託的那些單子比的話
你掛單的時間也會在他前面
那所以就算出價未成
通常也是程式單出價未成
就是你這樣子手動掛也都不太會出價未成
所以
就是
可能
例如說
就是要看你是什麼策略啦
那我舉例
如果你停歷100次
然後才會遇到一次
這個出價未成的話
那你出價未成那一次可能
少賺了30點
那但是你
這個
多滑架了100次
那你可能多滑架了100多點
那
這個100多點的多滑架跟你少停歷一次比起來
絕對是
損失超級巨大的價值
所以
就是
出場的話一定要用限價
然後
這個
呃
停損的話要用出價
然後這個操作的順序是這樣
這個
就是你
進場之後
你應該先去掛停損單
然後再去掛停歷單
因為
就是
有可能你一進場
然後就
就往
這個
反方向發動一個幾十點的行情嘛
所以
停損一定是要最優先掛上去的
那如果你掛進去之後就往上噴
那直接噴到
這個
239害你沒停歷到
那也不會怎樣嘛
你就多賺20點
所以操作是
進場之後
先
我這邊寫12
就是因為
要先去按
這個
出價停損單
然後
二
再去掛
限價停歷單
好
這個是一個操作的細節啦
然後
這也是為什麼我們學習要有教練嘛
就是
如果沒有教練的話
這個學生可能永遠都不會發現他操作有這個問題
而且
在他提出這個問題之後
這個群組是有很多人表示
欸對他也
他也目前停歷都是在用出價
然後
這個一直在
滑價損失價值
所以
這個
我想這應該會是非常多人的
一個問題啊
就是
如果你是在固定點數之外
停歷的話
請你掛限價單
不然長期而言
這個
細節上會損失很多的價值
好啦
今天就這樣啦